letztens habe ich mir das Video
angeschaut was jetzt wirklich nicht so
ganz der Brüller war aber man muss ja
ganz klar sagen Humor ist subjektiv was
sagt man nicht zu seinem Kind am ersten
Schultag
habe den Tag
ich glaube meine Mutter damals zu mir
gedacht setz dich neben den schlausten
da kannst du abschreiben
ist nach Hause und so Mama neben mir
sitzt
und ihr habt ihr alle kräftig
kommentiert 50 Humor ü 60 Humor und die
erste Person die mir eingefallen sie ist
wirklich lustig finden könnte war meine
Mutter ich habe mir das Video dann
einfach mal geschickt und bin davon
ausgegangen dass wir fleißig
weitergeleitet in die ein oder andere
whatsapp-gruppe war dann aber nicht der
Fall ist was für die allmans kannte ich
schon aus deinem Video allmanns
natürlich ich weiß nicht ganz genau ob
sie weiß was es ist
und eins kann ich euch sagen wenn selbst
meine Mutter das nicht witzig findet
dann ist es wirklich nicht witzig